voilà je prends pas pour la nouvelle
année évidemment moi qui ai une
nombreuse famille il a fallu que je
distribue des jouets et à propos des
enfants je me souviens qu'un jour on m'a
demandé
on m'a dit mais vous qu'il y avait des
enfants est ce que est ce que vous leur
dites enfin je parle pour mon aîné qui
va sur ses quinze ans maintenant et je
les lis très jeune et non mais je dis ça
mais il faut sauver la face alors on m'a
dit mais ce que vous lui avez est-ce que
vous avez pris un jour votre garçon à
part pour lui dire didon voilà mon vieux
comment ça se passe les choucha alors
j'aime était difficile de répondre
autrement qu'en revers alors j'ai écrit
huit petits verres que je vais vous dire
ça fait comme ça si vous avez des
garçons de 15 ans je vais vous donner
mon adresse il vous en verrez la
brochure voilà le rosier ne sait pas
comment se font les roses la lionne à
des lionceaux sans avoir rien appris et
mais se reproduire est dans l'ordre des
choses moi-même je laisse eu son combat
n'ait rien dit laissez donc la nature
expliquer ces mystères laissez vos
enfants croire aux enfants dans les
choux ils seront en leur temps ce qu'il
convient de faire et ce qu'ils devront
faire ils le feront sans vous
[Applaudissements]
dans notre immeuble il y a aussi une
boutique d'antiquités une élégante
boutique tenue par deux et les grands
antiquaires son enseigne porte ou deux
hortense échoué ils ont échoué depuis le
temps que je dis faut penser au titre
valide rose qui sont nos amis pris le
commandement du lait de petit calibre
aux gones sont vendus alors si on
continue à les avoir vite rires et des
clients pouvaient commander le pas on va
être en protégeant notre inculture je
voulais pas garder frais alors les deux
petites et alignera by labat une
habitude avec yahoo quand tu avais une
option sur des rames sur ce qui les a
pris elle voyait ou la robe qu'elle
était finalement à la voyez à l'abri des
deux parce qu'elle voulait faire un 14e
a besoin de moi j'écris parce qu'alors
si ça continue comme ça dans vie sur le
port permet de continuer à ne plus rien
avoir du tout mais c'est bien ça
d'ailleurs c'est pas sais pas ce qui se
passe en ce moment il ya un rush sur
l'antiquité je passe plus tôt il a
laissé leur succès 4 6 mois je suis
empreint du makoko la grille des coups
là qu'est ce qu'on en fait on la jette
ou quoi
les coudes ne me pose pas cette question
je t'ai je te jeter jeter les a répondu
si on n'a rien d'un magasin se balancent
se séparer de materia gelagri la vidéo
où elle habite et où elle est très jolie
qu'elle avait redorée on apprend revue
c'est tout à part régularisons -
lampadaires non messieurs c'est terminé
c'est la france comme on remonte tout
trader vient pourquoi parce que comme un
pauvre clients se disputant le cas avec
cette boîte de cirage que madame lennard
m'a demandé de monter en a rajouté
encore largement le fait jouer l'équipe
fanion messieurs bonjour monsieur
mb je sens que je ne vais pas vous
désirez quelque chose au chai besoin de
différentes choses je m'installe c'est
pousser pousser pousser vos chiens
aboient attendez attendez alors alors à
ce moment là si c'est pour chez vous il
faut que tu fasses des baquets je vous
ferai les petits paquets il fallait les
décorations je crois qu'ils les choses
comme ça oui alors je voudrais avoir un
renseignement oui
dans ce but là oui je dois savoir en
quoi vous êtes mobile est présentement
dans charlemagne en charge charlemagne
nommé fin charlemagne à cheval sur fins
charlemagne et directoire
ça c'est un grand cheval et la gare puis
sont deux époques qui vont bien ensemble
et c'est très chic pas qui colle même
avis que moi monsieur vous avez alors la
grande table de pierre alors oui j'ai le
menhir à vavoua et mignonne manière on
fait avec sa wii avec des boues qui se
rabattent à nyon nombreux non d'un seul
bloc et on soldera ce joli 0 1 éliminé
c'est très bien on revient on nous
donnait on vous la fait monter en a pas
d'air nous verrons bien te souviens la
lure savez mots bien lorsque ses soli
jolies qu'elles courent ça nous a fait
un usage qui dit quoi une autre chance
beaux murs a son importance aussi dans
l'animation générale vos murs sont
peints ou tapissés grand son petit nain
dans tout en mosaïque vous savez à la
turquie avec les médias la mosaïque on
peut paraître une foule de choses non
c'est quand même limité celui de manière
un peu avec ses limites et c'est quand
même assez persuadé qu'il sera temps
soeur je vois ça y'a ka paul louis saez
et puis sa vie avec sa patte et
envisageons puristes quelques coups mais
vraiment rare oui il a raison il a
raison montredon montredon le monsieur
le petit secrétaire michel qui viennent
de rentrer en boîte et si c'est une
montre s'engage à rien de le faire dans
le passé je voudrais vous poser une
question vous ne pensez pas que ce soit
trop fragiles non à ça vous savez sont
quand même des meubles qu'ils ont deux
cents ans là bas il convient courant ce
sera évidemment il faut pas laisser lui
mais dictée non impossible
est-ce que vous avez l'eau courante chez
vous ah oui j'ai l'eau courante ou alors
ça voyez je me déplace même parce que je
sais la réponse de nancy ne suis pas mal
à son aimable d'une susceptibilité aussi
vous pouvez pas vous rendre compte c'est
comme des gosses sorti après tous ces
mois ci comme des grands garçons et
bosser comme des gros buzz or on a
failli avoir happé pas terrible
d'ailleurs avec avec le fauteuil en
fauteuil un cauchemar fauteuil louis xiv
à y avoir des envies d'ailleurs
asseyez vous ça vous qui êtes
collectionneur c'est une pdm papillon
salut revoir à protester tyra clowe
regardez bien combien de temps fort yat
j'ai pas trois mois et demi à 3 avril et
a avoué qu'elle va rapper rapporte souci
des soucis pas bref un beau jour nous
avons vendu à des clients de passage
jeudi des gens par intéressant d
toujours d'une attraction des pièces
très beaux fauteuils étaient
authentiques en bas et a signé oui tu as
signé louis xiv joué 14 j'ai passé des
briques à tampa c'est fait monsieur
frère du roi vraiment été super bien été
plus délicat de trouver superbe où les
prisons libyennes
bref le fauteuil ne sait pas plus je ces
gens là n'est ce pas c'est à dire qu'on
lui a fait des réflexions et des
réflexions méchant non ces gens là
méritait pas de française dans ce
fauteuil du fer or il n'est pas de style
on a été refait son la mission ne
l'aurais pas acheté quand on est content
que ça demande beaucoup de vent il faut
d'ores et bien je ne sais pas on ne sait
pas
lowe's sais pas si c'est ça m'a pas
toujours victime qui saignait à dépérir
a sectionné
il a perdu sa forme et c'est devenu un
tout petit peu sinon je vous demander
qu'on repose et le sne d'affaires on
leur demande si je veux pas tout
simplement alors prendre une table aux
ags table dans un grain oui c'est autre
chose c'est autre chose bien fait pas
mal non plus je vous rappelle enfin que
je pars d'or et voyez monsieur de toute
façon faut toujours faire redorer oui
surtout les cinq en lice à si on veut
que ça va jonathan soit peu le symbole
on a intérêt à faire dorer bien sûr et
alors maison on pense qu'il serait
peut-être pas mal à ce moment là je
pense à des choses que j'ai peur si
monsieur adopté ce principe de la table
ça va un peu du passé
ce qui serait peut-être bien c'est une
babiole lazio n'a pas eu non relié à un
petit show sais pas où un petit détail
comme ça une petite tasse de style petit
à l'époque soit les traditions
merveilleux et alors qu'elle rêvait elle
est ancienne mais je pense qu'elle ne
riez pas la même pas doré sans les
motifs n'ont pas de raisons émotives ses
parents maya ça en vrai c'est vous la
procurer marquant la fin du jeûne et de
préférence pas encore semaines n'ont
plus tellement fragile je trouve que ce
serait plus difficile a les mêmes moyens
même jusqu'à dire si elle n'avait pas
tout à fait la même forme et bien
j'aimerais autant voyez oui oui oui vous
êtes fixés s'en sortent pas si oui alors
oui alors effectivement nous avons nous
avons un article 102 rue louis en bois
oui d'une forme un petit peu différente
100 ans mais avec quatre pieds ne me
gêne pas du tout seulement c'est plus
une tasse et un escabeau c'est le seul
ennui mais enfin barça
oui mais j'en ai déjà alors si vous en
avez rien tant pis alors je me suis en
mesure non seulement vous entendez ici
on ne sait pas ce que voulez vous je ne
me plaît je me laisse sur une pièce
d'abord un livre non mais c'est de
thérèse-marie manière c'est à dire mais
moi ce à quoi on était battu c'est pour
un ebe pour un salon c'est quoi annoncer
pour mon armoire
bon eh oui j'ai une grande armoire vide
alors je veux la meubler
qu'est ce que vous me conseillez ça les
enfants foyer jeune maître décembre
comme motif décoratif 5
oui m'avait sodomie des simples mourir
non pas des retraits bien nourris pas
forcément ma faim
vous ne craignez pas que ça fasse un peu
nu des cintres seul comme ça quand même
je viens vous seul pouvez y accrocher
des chaumes et vous alors moi j'ai suivi
d un père par exemple au mieux la banque
pour quelques billets de même vraiment
vraiment les versions pré mais alors jma
sur la planche dessus alors quelques
concerts 31 en panne hier cédric oui ou
alors moi je pense est carrément aller
sa maison de bretagne en leur panel on
va déroule le mondial est sûre de moi
alors alors non je serai à goutte
alors comme je dis moi j'ai dit ça ne va
pas ça ne va pas je vous donne mon avis
je suis d'autant plus désolé que j'avais
un cadeau à faire j'ai écouté monsieur
monsieur si vous n'êtes pas trop pressé
honte et essayez de vous le procurer ce
cas oui mais c'est un cadeau pour une
cérémonie va alors tout cas assez
précises pour un mariage ou un baptême
loin des 16 go une veuve
ah bon vous aviez quelques jours en vue
non pas spécialement petit une petite
console pour une box de loupe les arrêts
très bien le français louis xiv
ça peut être amusant mais c'est déjà une
dame d'un certain âge nous avons
plusieurs points saint louis xiii qui
est très bien où je vais de vous à moi
j'aurais préféré faire un cadeau moins
important écoutez monsieur enfin pas à
la fin des fins dans quel genre l'arrêt
de cette page avait vu quelque chose il
y avait quelque chose que cette fin
d'été de mettet nous sommes là pour vous
êtes en présence aussi j'ai veillé sur
des vidéos de moi j'allais dire juillet
sur soi savoir quoi on veut dire c'est
une espèce de l'espèce de quoi faire de
machin qui voit un service à café
nous tenons en une seule pièce non
seulement à 6.171 obéit directoire donc
le large mais chez un porteur et
enveloppes tepa manneken pis
non je crois que ça s'appelle comme ça
l'a aidé non maintenant avec une queue
un chien non au maintien de par un chien
mais c'est pour quoi faire et frites
d'horreur une fois encore voici voilà
une fois la france de faire me suis
alors dit je sais pas ce qui me retient
vous jetez un rapport de cette boutique
du monde
ok c'est que ça c'est rien ça mais ça
sert à quoi ça sert à rien à rien on me
dit que c'est rare hors alice image est
quasiment introuvable en que c'est
curieux c'est absolument inutile le
faire à sa solution je vous le garantie
sur facture
comment ça s'appelle un sert à rien
d'ailleurs c'est le nom et ne pas
confondre avec le sheikh à tous les spas
qui a la même forme et on peut servir à
l'envi pour mitch là vous me jurez que
ça ne peut être d'aucune utilité te
plait monsieur c'est semble égal points
sont à la hausse et parce que c'est le
prince sept poissons de l'institut de
contrôle ne sert à rien il a été essayé
de m'envoyer un poinçon ce qu'on peut
vraiment rien en faire sa seigneurie
passe moi si j'étais sûr que ça ne
servait strictement à rien je crois que
je me laisserais pas ôté monsieur mais
j'écoutais moi bien monsieur si vous
pouvez en faire le moindre usage moi je
vous le reprend et pensait alors c'est
une folie mais tant pis je lâche
attendait pourtant des débats et connais
je vais essayer je vais essayer à mon
tour de main comme de vous en procurer
un semblable vous n'allez pas que vous
n'avez pas le même malheureusement
celui-ci est vendu je peux pas leur en
coûte mais franchement vous souhaitez
prendre la parole chaque fois que je
vous demande quelque chose dont je
dépends brute est en jeu c'est pas une
fois à quoi ça ressemble et intérêts
ainsi qu'à vous avez une boutique à
leurs fins de mois quelque chose ah non
mais vous ne connaissez pas je me suis
juré de faire une acquisition jeu-là
fasciste chercherait pas d'ici là
monsieur on ne refuse pas la borde et
qu'on en a un abandonnera la ville aura
quelques secondes on n'a rien on a rien
dans des bons la retirer ou alors si
gaza où la saveur à cet article la vie à
ça c'est moche car ça lui a envahie que
tu ne vas pas me faire aux écoutes moi
non je suis trop commerçants va changer
quelque chose quelque chose avant que je
ne sorte ma vous me donnez une idée de
quelle époque et il se nomme eric
naulleau si tu peux attention ça va
tomber irie a su frapper
tu veux me laisser l'expliqué avec le
client à peu le cas les poches en servir
à quelle époque mois arts décoratifs
c'est pas une copie non ce que je trouve
que vous allez venir ce qui n'est pas
plus jeunes qui le parraine les montres
toile
je ne vous permets pas je suis
authentique vraiment monsieur tout ce
que nous avons ici et anciens vous
l'apprendrez et puis regardez les coins
si vous vous y connaissez vous regardez
les coins pas une moisissure au coin
bien sûr les pierres fun on est haut
plus loin encore il est piqué l'avez
vous aimez c'est la variole ce ne sont
pas les verts c'est donc
mais qu'est ce que je vais en faire
cfoot manqué d'imagination pour un grand
jeune homme de votre âge qu'est ce qu'on
peut en faire une tanche elle parce que
ça c'est joli de torchères une torchère
un petit [ __ ] de venise pas mon noir
avec un flambeau dans les bras dans un
vestibule ce jeu mais nous voyons ne
veux pas qu'on paye en noir et or bien
ça va brasser suffit comme ça et il se
plonge avec difficulté une chose nous
bravo les brestois de sopi très bien on
peut en faire un travail et que tu vois
il ya qu'à changer ce taux avec les
petits tiroirs secrets derrière nos
attentes ou bien une autre utilisation
possible encore une chose qui garnissent
plus coupée en deux peut-être le on
porte moto pour accrocher des chapeaux
le banc porte-parapluie une fois qu'ils
se rhabiller qu'est ce que vous dites de
ça au manque de chance et a des maux
femen entendu pas attendu avant les
notaires
bien entendu monsieur si vous me prenez
je vous leur avis les deux cas je me
dégage la nuque et jouit le pont
s'annonce à se faire par conséquent même
le client est roi il commande on
s'incline
nous n'avons pas le droit de refuser
l'avant c'est trop dur tout ce qu'on a
tous nos enfants bon alors d'accord tu
me vends bien qu'aucune van sant avec un
bel art à jour et on en pâtit
avant qu un coude
[Musique]
alors edou edou célibataire bien non
vous marier oui les boeufs nom est
avancé
un nom visuel de votre femme mon visuel
dates et lieux de notre mariage croyez
voir si justement c'était c'était ce que
je ferai après monsieur ne copiez pas
par monsieur de marché non non non ça
c'est s'il ya une cuisine que je n'aime
pas du tout c'est ma paye d'infos
laziale ma feuille d'impôts mais jeu et
même loin de dominer loin de doigts
millet de moi l'idée de vous donner des
explications c'est évoluer explique t d
des éclaircissements à revoir les
nouvelles complications de la notice
simplificatrice prix mais je crois
pouvoir ici sans une tribu dans ce faire
profiter de mon expérience
ceux qui chaque année comme vous comme
moi devant leur feuille d'impôt la piste
peut balancer pallice de peur car si
comme l'a dit gerville dans l'énéide
comme la vie dire gilles comme la vidéo
de l'adie pour ville l'a dit socrate ou
dases fort tu vas nous gâte aux affaires
ohada robert rôdât daouda d'autres c'est
du latin
enfin ça veut dire faut du culot pour
réussir et les autres ne doivent pas se
laisser dominer par ce complexe de
culpabilité
c'est pas ce complexe de l'ugb la kilbi
de ligue b a culbuté que vous connaissez
bien et qui les empêchera toujours de
bien la digérer la rédiger et c'est
pourquoi moi qui vous parle je fuis
trouvé mon certes espère c'est mon père
pasteur complément pertes mots son
remplaçant d'ailleurs je lui demander de
bien vouloir jeter un tout petit google
un tout petit coup de blues une noyade
sur ma première déclaration
ma première avec ma première feuille
c'est à dire c'était pas ma première
fait la première à effet des fat et
j'avais fait des pâtes et des personnes
qui ont la plume facile moi c'est la
langue aussi utile aujourd'hui on
n'écrit plus on parle enfin bref la
deuxième j'avais déclaré trond
la troisième je n'ai plus rien déclaré
du tout la quatrième j'avais plus de
feuilles à fabrègues c'était la septième
et bien je suis contrôleur mettez vous
désirez avec monsieur si vous êtes trop
longues heures si vous êtes trop content
trop si vous l'êtes
ça tombe bien parce que justement je
crains que vous ne vous soyez vous voyez
vous ne vous soyez foot de payer ses
erreurs dans leurs auteurs des poteaux
qui se demandent le report des poteaux à
la page 2 voyons d'abord la page eux
dit-il propriétés bâties je ne vois rien
je disais justement peu moi non plus et
non bâti sa non bâti gens mentent pas et
là et bien là
ah s'il faut payer les résidences
secondaires et secondaires très
secondaire mais j'en ai qu une en tout
cas je n'étais pas forcé de lui dire que
j'avais été à la santé jour ma mère me
que j'avais été à la mer pour ma santé
et personnes à votre service personne ne
vous piché pas de moi il me dit vous
ficher pas de mal vous faites tout tout
seul et non bien sûr j'ai ma femme c'est
tout c'est pas le facteur l'éboueur dame
au ciel que nous sommes nul ne peut se
vanter de se passer des hommes que je
lui dis mais vous cacher des cachets
pardon je fous là des salaires qui sont
presque invisibles pouvait pas lui
avouer que c'était les cachets de la
radio d'arrêter la diffusion de la radio
dérivé de la snrt est que j'avais
frauduleusement doublé par souci de la
vraisemblance déjà votre compte est bon
ce soit et vous qui sont d'ailleurs à
nantes a du coup t'as pas tout papa pas
du tout non si c'est la somme en somme
qu'on me sandra de payer plus 10% après
la date il dit ah oui mais après quelle
date
ça j'en sais rien ça dépend du rôle mais
10% c'est sûr
alors là j'ai compris je n'ai rien dit
je ne me suis pas laissé faire
j'ai filé à la poste et j'ai tout payé
d'un seul coup 10 pour cela à hasnon en
ajoutant sur mon talent sur mon talon
monsieur c'est peut être un devoir pour
tous francs mais soyez un français moyen
de payer ses pinceaux de ppc ayew 2 2
gasquet mais c'est un devoir envers ses
enfants de ne pas verser un centime de
plus et en costume d'homme en proscrit
montreuil en proche
or en bas et vous devez le savoir vous
ce que vous êtes père de ma fille
vous êtes père de famille comme moi ah
non non non tout est beau mais complexé
jamais
[Applaudissements]
mais à présent il faut varier un petit
peu vous interpréter une tranche de vie
angélique nous avons ramené au camp dans
nos nombreux périples dans les usines
parisienne
ça s'intitule la chaîne g
crac panpan pin pas boeing gut terminé
quilit-quilit terminé crack up bin a
trop in good terminé quilit-quilit
terminé trac patent mines pas aux in
blood qui en guinée c'est la pause à
aller auront lieu dimanche et belle
fille comme ça il encore qui fait que
les filles doit commencer ton truc toi
comment tu fais que les trottoirs comme
celle contre et de kouaoua alors mal au
mal c'est facile alors moi je l'appelle
craque elle arrive par roba rateur à
saillon bouche un coin
bein je remède à la maison boeing son
fauteuil basculant est terminée et toi
comment cette eau brute la commande
directe pépite commencer ton truc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
garçon garçon s'il vous plaît je
voudrais un café crème avec deux croient
ça je m'excuse monsieur nous n'avons
plus du tout de croissance
enfin ça fait rien alors je vais prendre
autre chose ça fait il y en a tellement
dans nuit entre nous un chacun dans sa
vie privée on n'a que des soucis l on va
pas s'en faire entre nous vous avez
quand donner un café nature à leur café
nature avec deux croient ça que je
m'excuse je me suis peut-être mal
exprimé je vous dis que les croissants
nous n'avons plus on n'a plus du tout
croissant
là ça change tout si un appui je peux
pas en avoir forcément ça fait rien je
parle d'autre chose alors je prendre
n'importe quoi du lait et du lait et
bien donné moins d'une tasse de lait
avec deux croient ça ça va pas vous êtes
un peu fatigué ou non je vous dis que
les croissants on n'en n'avons plus
c'est ce que c'est que les croise un
décroissant des bretzels des brioches
oui des croissants non faut pas vous
énervez pour ça mais ça fait rien
écoutez je suis pas le client beta je
vais vous dire donnez moi ce que vous
voulez je peux pas mieux vous dire du
thé et du chocolat au lait et un
chocolat au lait de croissance a dit
d'abord nous avons longtemps habité ce
garçon je vous connais pas moi je suis
client monsieur je suis comme vous
j'étais derrière la colonne vous m'avez
peut-être pas vu mais moi je vous ai
entendu vous n'êtes pas malade lors
qu'est ce qui vous prend dans petit
garçon et gna gna gna gna gna gna
taisez vous laissez moi vous dire
monsieur que vous avez de la chance
d'avoir à faire un garçon qui a de la
patience parce que - garceau si j'avais
à votre place il ya longtemps que
j'aurais pris les deux croissants
je les aurai [ __ ] sur la gueule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans notre série aventure aux à l'ouest
nous sommes heureux et fiers de vous
présenter une superproduction
cinémascope et en technicolor
intitulé d'après le sondage tom mix en
français le retour de tom mix avec dans
le rôle principal
rodgers pierre ce big star entourée des
célèbres acteurs rollmops tomato ketchup
les deux petites jumelles les soeurs
blue jeans et sofia du plantain la
vedette qui pousse c'est une
superproduction de la métro goldwin
meyer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kolingba my taylor is rich bataille dr
ronald wayne callies mesdames et
messieurs excusez mon camarade il ne
sait pas que vous ne parlez pas tous
l'anglais alors voici si vous le voulez
bien maintenant la version doublée en
français de lanceurs de tom mix le
retour de tom mix c'est à dire que nous
allons donner une voix françaises à ses
lèvres américaine laisse pas version
post synchronisée comme on dit au studio
le gène villiers dans la scène auto 883
merci
[Musique]
soit reléguant content de vous revoir
ouais je vous avais dit que je
reviendrais cinq ans jour pour jour je
suis fidèle au rendez-vous pas vrai nom
l'âge la guerre ne sera pas déterrer du
côté des montagnes rocheuses aigle noir
m'a dit la vérité celui qu'a fait
thierry tome chine s'est hissée parmi
vous plaît m'est avis qu'il va y avoir
de la bagarre
vous êtes convié e sarbe antilles et les
autres ouais celui qui a fait le coup a
perdu un éperon à sa botte gauche a été
trahie weston tu as gardé ta bonne
couche et l'assassin n'avait pas des
pompes 7 est un piège à mouches par metz
toulouse mais pierrefeu a tant pis pour
toi
pas terrible ça ne s'est pas faire les
coups de feu
[Musique]
on dirait de l'eau chaude mais n'arrive
pas à faire les fonctionnements pardon
justice est faite sur la table pour
reprendre le droit chemin liga la guerre
de sécession à ccc sont encore là-bas la
guerre de sécession et finit pas en vrai
et nous devons nous remettre au travail
enfin si content de vous revoir série je
ne connais pas trop rire intelligent
bref là aussi je me sens tout timide
chéri vous avez fait quoi
je voudrais tant vous et vous est compté
est ce que votre père est décédé
il est probable viol un pardon
est ce que votre bd décidé l'an passé
c'est un vieux renard c'est si bon de
trouver sans perdre une minute pour sûr
je vais monter sur mon cheval et je ne
dirai qu'un mot
le monde est sûrement sur les jeunes
puisque ce genre de son choix les jeunes
dirait qu'un mot la mémé ya un mois je
peux pas lire là et je ne dirai qu'un
mon chéri commencé moi ta porte
[Rires]
[Musique]
hu anne-marie je me suis je pense à
quelqu'un d'autre est tombé d'accord de
mettre en colère regardez les ils fuient
tous comme des lapins
si fort
ah oui chérie tu nous n'attendrons pas
l'avis de votre père vous avez grossi
poursuivre c'est la choucroute oui nous
allons nous marier monde en jaune rossi
loges
nous allons de mariée mélange dans la
petite église en place pour fuir mingora
et devant toute la famille réunie pour
sûr nous serons unis pour la vie oui
vous mettrez votre belle replancher vos
grosses chaussures à clous et nous
partirons tous les deux d'un pas
tranquille sur le chemin du bonheur
c'est fini au parc des combes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
examinateurs c'est pas un métier ils
veulent tous avoir leur permis se donne
même pas la peine d'apprendre le code de
la route
enfin avec moi pas question de par trois
premiers candidats
bonjour monsieur monsieur vous vous
trouvez sur une route à grande
circulation n'est ce pas vous croisez
une route départementale dont la largeur
et double de celle d'un chemin vicinal
qui la prolonge au sud-ouest d'une ligne
médiane rasées par le bas côté d'une
route secondaire parallèle à celle comme
les éviter en empruntant le trajet
inverse de celui inscrit sur un panneau
indicateur placé derrière il pleut votre
essuie-glaces tombe en panne café d'eau
je vous ai posé une question précise
monsieur je vous prie de répondre oui
bon vous ne savez pas et bien vous
viendrez dans trois mois monsieur roquet
merci beaucoup
oui ces séries dégagé parce qu'il ya
d'autres candidats
oui c'est sa frappe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mira candidats suivants suivant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les papas les flammes
asseyez-vous n'entend prendre un petit
remontant dans l'examen d'agent sur ne
soient les animaux quand même
mais eux
vous êtes bien installé ça va comme vous
voulez ben ça me gêne un peu les genoux
l' hary mais c'est une petite voiture un
wifi chez des gros genou
la mieux les genoux la prochaine fois on
a un autocar il ya intérêt posthume
changerait pour mes genoux bon monsieur
première question vous montez dans votre
voiture celle-ci ne veut pas démarrer
que faites vous ce que chez vous ah bah
vous feriez bien le savoir vous montez
dans votre voiture elle ne démarre pas
qu'est ce que vous faites
ben je descends ah oui la manivelle
d'ange des 100 plus grands coups de
pompes dans cette saloperie de bagnols
l'impresion capot le point de créer un
mollet qui chasse le moteur en mille
morceaux joffre à joburg
mais je suis pas du genre à mes
s'emmerder permettra de faire un lien et
puis pas par autre chose non plus
d'ailleurs
suis-je assez clair
bon autre chose me suivre et à présent
vous arrivez à un carrefour
un agent de la force publique nous fait
signe de vous arrêter
qu'est ce que vous faites je pense
je vois pas sa vie gérome sur la buffet
et au passage ou mapaq qui régit balance
un bon coup de pompe dans la poêle même
occasion monsieur s'est pas appliqué à
faire la loi aidera sonné pour tous le
siège
maintenant vous êtes sur une route
départementale robinson étonnant est ce
que vous dites j ça m'étonnerait je
choisis sur une route départementale
j'y vais jamais sur les routes
départementales j'ai plein de boue et ça
sent mauvais suit une j'entends bien
monsieur mais c'est une supposition vous
êtes sur une route départementale
non
je suis pas sur une route départementale
je viens de vous dire que j'y met jamais
les pieds sur les routes départementales
j'aime pas ça les routes départementales
je les routes départementales les autres
départements hôtel rien que de mon côté
ça donne envie d'envoyer des mandats
dans la conche à tout ce qui remet mais
un admettra pas très mal faire quoi
et un deuxième mail farcir le petit
asticot à à merveille vous commencé à
m'énerver avec vos questions est-ce que
je vous en pose des questions brest je
vous entends est ce que je vous demande
qu'est ce que vous faites espace aussi
qu'est ce que vous faites si ce pas cela
du tout parce que je vous oblige à le
surnom départementales gérées plus je
vous demande pourquoi vous avez cette
tête d'abruti ouais mais pourquoi tu as
tu appris les vielles ton charme eu un
la seule chose que je demande c'est si
beau m'a donné mon père mais oui ou non
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire comme temps
formalité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cc paraît déjà cinq heures et est
thématique femmes qui viennent chercher
à sera la sortie des du du palais et bah
va pas trouver de place a encore avait
encore s'énerver puis 10 puis ce soir ça
va encore être là la soupe à la grimace
à eybens un coup de chance et c'est le
même avocat qui va plaider les deux
affaires s'il pouvait aller vite ça
m'arrangerai à bonjour bonjour m alors
voilà à m'être dit moi je suis assez
pressé alors les trois accusés ne ne
sont pas là alors par défaut tous les
toits alors si vous pouviez français ça
m'arrangerait couvrement saad haddad
accord tête elles à la flèche rapide par
la redoutable beau bondirait dans
l'espace mais si c'est bien pour vous à
plaisir parce que d'habitude j'aime peut
peser chaque mot maintenable à autre
chose fougueux 8 août toujours comme ça
abbas alors c'est bizarre vous êtes deux
premiers kim ne s'en soit rendu compte
il m'a béni ilmane d'arriver en arrive
de 10 payer comme ça quand j'ai trop fou
fou fourvoyé avec les femmes
alors moi vallée des femmes couples up
sa coupe et coupe la parole
reid didot vous vous avez un sacré à
rennes
et êtes-vous pourquoi se dit pourquoi
c'est typiquement stupide ben moi ça ou
pas curieux ça serait plutôt le
contraire c'est le manque de rapport
avec ma femme qui me fait bébé pays
comme ça d'ailleurs ce que vous voyez là
la gueule qu'elle avoue comprendre y abè
et ça ne s'est pas aidé été étonnant
quand on voit votre google a voulu vous
et vous aimez vous savez ça ne me gêne
pas parce que le cran quand on voit
celle de de gainsbourg ça vous encourage
ça marche pas mal pour lui un bon
j'allais trêve de plaisanterie co
comment vous appelez-vous alphonse des
premières troupes boutora terrazza tisci
voilà alors si vous permettez pour aller
plus plus vite jouer vous appeler al
alpes enfants font ce giro aussi vite
que bonds à l'épreuve premier à faire
affaire là n'arrivent qu'est ce qui lie
la fée bat votre larible 1-1 insultes à
agent rachid avant alors qu'est ce qu'il
a dit exactement la wilaya il ait ihya
qui m'auront veut mort ou vol y calmez
vous je comprends votre émotion mais
morrow yabiladi mauvais moment 5 heures
d'un stade la fâcherie
vous l'avez de le dire à quelqu'un
qu'est ce que je dis ex exactement j'ai
dit 5 5h10 mais la fhp de grandir
apprennent et après vous avez quelques
est ce que j'ai dit mais la fasch vous
voulez vais t'expliquer papier toilé
peut pas parce ce que j'ai dit et deux
mois avec deux mois avec deux mois deux
mois faire je me suis dit moi je suis
die penser à écouter j'ai pas beaucoup
de temps vous m'en voyez leurs espaces
thématiques de de demain matin les
médias à dire dans la ferme moore en
chalets etc est allé vite qu'est ce qui
a fait votre môme manche abc fut il
fumait de la mariée il fumait d'abord il
fut immédiat marié dammarie garrec et
mari de fanny sirop hanna ont la main
marijuana alors 2 2 en fait un nom dans
sa phase obama doit ce client qui me
tient à coeur à la dudh était désolé ce
genre de truc je n'admets pas 2,2
enfants d'adam kaikai cas qui râlent
mais vous moi j'ai juba pays bas
plaidoiries à palumbo 87 pages après
après jeu rapide comme la veille ouais
ouais chef de salle au foro profité 2 2
de la situation pas parce que ma femme
est elle tourne autour d'une parade du
bon aller 1-1 dans un drame un homme de
noces avec hulu com comment commencer ma
plis plaidoirie pour aller on va
s'arranger six 6 mois
donc vous pouvez crever non mes yeux non
messieurs
bon allez and 1 1 à moi merde c'est pas
beaucoup un mémoire
ta gueule non messieurs bon je dors à 2
à l'aller en attaque
allez allez allez les lieux qu aller à
kaka capoolco à qui ponctuera les dagues
ait eu beau ballet travers lui de 2,2 en
faire avant chez cgg jamais pu dire à
qui tu es venu apache a jamais plus une
direct avec c'est fini c'est curieux ça
c'est fini alors vous
[Applaudissements]
allocations de chômage ouais comme tous
les mois coiffer la routine quoi
mais ça fait longtemps que vous venez
vous ça fait bien six ans non avatar
j'avais raison
vous rentrez dans votre septième année
de pointe h déjà comme le temps passe et
vingt dix ans ça nous rajeunit pas tout
ça demain dimanche je me rappelle les
débuts quand je venais pointer là il y
avait ma petite nièce elle va c'est que
moi otites et je n'ai connu autres comme
ça va vite et agrandie elle va rentrer
en sixième pendant que ça va toujours
même train-train jours ici un jour là
j'ai pas trouvé de travail encore n'ont
rien rires pourtant c'est pas les places
qui marque un mois vous savez les
meilleures places elles ont déjà été
prises à l'équipe au niveau attendu des
places à 800 mille sept cent mille six
cent mille par mois ils se sont servis
rats il arrive trop tard et vous
cherchez bien
bien sûr tous les matins je vais je
demande bonjour monsieur vous reste en
place a vu son mythe
non mais je sais déjà pris et à 700
milles à ce prix il ya six ans mini prix
gémeaux gym madame thérèse à 200
millions n'a pas eh bien vous savez à 70
à 80 millions à plein des places là
pourquoi google a plein pourquoi
personne n'en veut j'ai des coups par
mois je reviendrai à déplacer les
battements larves pas nouvelle fatwa et
me dit on veut pas vivre à la longue
vous ennuyer pas non on s'y fait on s'y
fait on s'y fait vous savez l'après midi
ce beau cinéma je reste deux ou trois
séances bien au chaud et puis quand
c'est fini je descends il arrive
doucement doucement cette heure je
descends café je regarde la télévision
jusqu'à la fin au noir et blanc lé
programme parce que la couleur là bas
ils vont nous la livrée que le mois
prochain
c'est tordu et puis comme ça j'en suis
moi vers l'est aujourd'hui
ça vous fait coucher tard tu sais mais
oui et oui mais je sens qu'il va arriver
un moment où je pourrai plus le faire ça
je le sens le sang mehdi el matador
heureusement je peux récupérer le matin
je me lève vers les 10 heures 11 heures
je vais faire un petit tour à la mairie
je vois certains secours à toucher ou
bien
retard d'allocations ça n'est pas stable
illustration n'est jamais tranquille
note la paperasserie la roya les
élections je vais voter je regarde les
bulletins je pense la matinée les
candidats y en a toujours des nouveaux
alors heureux car cela tient aux pires
est pointée offs il vivait nouveau site
une petite découverte et oui mais les
élections c'est tous les quatre on sait
qu'on est mieux que rien mais vous savez
le plus dur c'est pas ça le plus dur
c'est le cas le 14 juillet le 15 août le
premier mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'ennuie
les magasins fermés personnes au travail
est un calvaire
les longues journées 1 ça c'est très
long les jours fériés je peux pas les
voir
mais quand même votre famille vous
l'envoyez de temps en temps vos frères
et vos soeurs mais non ils travaillent
tous
il se lève à 6h du matin le travail en
banlieue naughty darty soi-disant part
en tournée toujours à droite à gauche
ma soeur elle travaille dans le métro
elle fait la nuit soit disant qu'ils
disaient ils appellent ça des brigades
faut savoir que si ces brigades là qui
font ça fait que je peux pas les voir on
n'a pas les mêmes horaires
ce problème et nous en mai mois surtout
moi surtout moi aussi voilà votre argent
petit albert dites moi oui
vous savez vous savez pas si on va être
augmentée prochainement
ah non j'ai rien entendu à ce sujet
comment vous avez entendu ça tu ne
savais pas comment tous les
fonctionnaires il ait augmenté et tous
les collègues de médecine où normalement
on doit suivre alors c'est à chez nous
y'a rien d'annoncé un ben ça c'est de la
pub ça m'a mise à pied j'ai ça va aller
mal hein qu'est ce qui leur pend au nez
c'est trop faire la grève
et attention nous confond fait la grasse
et peu de rigolade n ont fait la grève
illimitée loin attention
[Applaudissements]
ah le travail qui longe emma moffatt qui
encore en pagne de sacs de réparation la
semaine dernière elle est encore en
pagne ou le pain qui va se prendre dans
la tête le garagiste à faire très très
mal
c'est pas vrai ça 2 sag a dit non enfin
heureusement côté coeur là cette fois je
crois que j'ai carrément trouver le
bonheur
ah oui j'ai rencontré une maladie dont
allait super hyper extra c'est un mec
non quand je dis c'est un mec c'est une
façon de parler ou sais que tu vas
méfie-toi saborit tout à l'heure et
saraya pauvre mec attend que je te
raconte l'histoire tu essaies on était
aux voltigeurs la bois à gambetta
on était en train de se faire une petite
mousse tranquille peinard molopo mchip
est toutefois juste avant l'arrivée des
agents
et d'un seul coup il ya cette disquette
qui en dit long on aurait vu la classe
de la nana blonde et ou veste de cuir
futal de cuir avec les clous les aigles
et tout le bordel thouet nana qui jette
quand même tout de suite et que c'est
quand même assez rare
ou alors tu sais toujours ce qui se
passe là bas surtout à gambetta ksila s
et leur père quand même à chaque fois
qu'ils aient une ana qui sera même si
tout de suite les conneries comment
vas-tu de poils
et toile à matelas comme tu voiture à
brac tuer n'importe quoi c'est vrai les
nanas sa pelouse foot c'est normal 1
alors elle au lieu de sa vie dont tu
sais pas ce qu'elle fait elle attrape
une chaise comme ça et à fait eu il ya
quelqu'un qui est pas content là dedans
il ya un mec dans le fond au lieu de
s'écraser molopo chip est tout ouïe de
roupiller tranquillo spénard dans son
coin le tard et il lève le doigt à vide
au lieu de travail un coup de genou dans
le bide le pif écrasé deux yeux au
beurre noir
le mec qui s'est retrouvé par terre les
moustaches en croatie le cas où il a
failli souffler son gaz via leur a été
tellement énervée claquement sec fri des
grands coups de pompes au maire ma pompe
qui encore déchiré lyon un sac de
réparation la semaine dernière elle est
encore déchiré le pain qui va se prendre
dans la tête le marchand de chaussures
ça faire très très mal à séparer te voir
le garagiste et le marchand de pont
pirouette jumeaux la semaine bref je
reviens à mon histoire c'est cette nana
m'avait vachement intéressé mois bon
c'est vrai c'est normal parce que tu
vois quand même plus souvent des mecs
qui castagne des mecs que moins fort que
que des nanas qui chie corps des mecs
c'est vrai c'est plus rare dans
l'ensemble alors moi je me suis dit
celle-là il n'y a pas de problème il
faut que j cause plus sa tombe est
vachement bien parce que j'étais super
bien ça paie enfin moi je trouve
j'avais les ray ban j'avais la chemise à
quoi la bague avec la tête de mort la
matraque soupe la chaîne de vélo tout le
bordel toi
alors je me suis ramené à côté d'elle
comme ça et je les regardais eu presque
dans les yeux toi j'y fais comment ça va
baby là tu me crois où tu me crois pas
là la nama fils une tarte j'ai fait
quatre tours et demi mais je me suis
retrouvé par terre c'est tout juste si
j'étais pas sorti de mes baskets non
mais tu vois un peu la gêne devant les
copains au le travail je savais plus
quoi faire toi même
il fallait bien que je me relève parce
que tu comprends la sueur ça dure qu'un
temps
1 alors je me suis relevé doucement je
les regardais comme ça vachement western
j'y fais consorts me fais ok ayant les
sorties et c'est quand on est arrivés
sur le trottoir toi moi j'avais eu le
temps de réfléchir je me suis dit quand
même qu'on est un mec une nana il ya
d'autres moyens de se fendre la gueule
que ce chic oreilles c'est vrai alors
j'ai dit on va faire un tour à me fais
ok alors on a sauté sur mon art ligue 1
maintenant c'est pas vraiment une harley
c'est à dire c'est une mob ordinaire que
j'ai rajouté un guidon style harley mais
pour la france c'est suffisant tu peut
frimer avec ça alors on a roulé roulé
roulé roulé roulé on s'est retrouvé au
moins je crois porte maillot toi tu es
là on s'est arrêté et on a causé est
très très très très vite on a compris
que on étaient faits l'un pour l'autre
surtout moi d'ailleurs j'ai dit je
trouve ça vachement chouette el ahmadi
qui a trouvé ça chouette aussi bref on
était déjà 2e à trouver ça chouette hein
et puis on s'est aperçu très vite qu'on
avait les mêmes idées sur la vie que
c'est quand même vachement important
quand on est un couple d'avoir les mêmes
idées sur la vie question entendre du
couple et tous sains et le coup
classique qui se passe toujours quand et
avec une disquette que tu as les mêmes
idées qu'elle sur la vie thouet tu as
envie de rouler une pelle et crac
bonjour madame on sait rouler une pelle
porte maillot
et depuis c'est carrément le zew bonheur
un nom là les problèmes parce que nous
et aia
non c'est pas qu'il ya des problèmes
vont aussi ya c'est que tu te rends
compte qu une nana qui chie quand les
mecs c'est pas toujours une nana facile
torrent elle est très très chef comme
d'un attrait très autoritaire selon moi
j'ai dit méfie-toi méfie toi je me
laisserais pas monté sur les embryons
non mais sans blague
qu'est ce que croient qu'on peut pas se
passer d'elle non mais peut très bien se
passer d'elle -10 2 perdu une de
retrouvée non mais veut dire ça comme
l'autre fois laquelle a pas voulu venir
au cinéma avec moi là un mois je suis
allé tout seul
et puis ça a rien changé parce que le
film il était aussi bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
se replier
merci moi je suis fan on cerne orienté
dont je suis juste une auteure
dramatique que j'ai fait un mètre 72 73
patrick selva merde je viens juste donné
un petit coup de balai fucké juste avant
que les autres numéros à ses maladresses
de bobinage au cl vous plaît merci
moi j'ai souvent la notion allocation ça
trop quel temps
cl vous plaît merci d'être venus les
sons de torchon c'est un mot plus moisi
travail sont 23 heures par semaine et
qu'ils y gagnent sont 43 francs par mois
sur quant au cerveau merci j'ai là que
je mange les conséquences crâne ego des
temps en temps les costco seront pour
permettrent j'ai arrêté car ça fait mal
au foie et aux reins mon dieu s'il vous
plaît
mais c est un peu le genre je suis
arrivé avec les voitures
je l'adoré je vendais le pigeon je
l'aide aux films avec les deux cracks
romagne et au bardo
j'ai ordonné albert john capitaine
haddock temps des mails au marché de
l'art mais à voir la navale l'aspect
plaidé dépend professeur tournesol
savons s'il vous plaît merci j'ai là que
des avec rocket au rétroviseur j'ai les
antibrouillards les klaxons
partant pour une choquante un seul beau
plus parce que quand on réfléchit
théo à la noisette ou dépense toute la
semaine tu verras que j'ai raison ces
replis merci avec les copains année la
caravane va me feront pour aller voir la
petite soeur est le grand père en suède
[Musique]
donc attention s'il vous plaît les
passagers du vol air france
numéro 320 à destination de marrakech
sont informés et ceci afin d'éviter
désormais tout elle entendu que le texte
qui va leur être présentées maintenant
et d'inspiration anti raciste merci
marrakech
ça nous a déçus nantes a nous a pas plu
c'est plein d'à pourtant nous on navigue
vers clichy et là y'en a des arabes à
mai à marrakech
y'a que ça non déjà à l'avion pour y
aller ça nous avait pas fait bonne
impression
c'est pas ta la question de la violence
l avion comme lionel nallet un congrès
de l'entreprise il avait plutôt bien
fait les choses
un petit avion ring pour nous et les
collègues de l'entreprise bien aucune
promiscuité bien mais c'est qu'un tas de
vue arriver l'aviateur ou quel malheur
vous savez pas qu'est-ce qui nous avait
trouvé comme agatha un arabe
eh bien je dis à ma moitié ça commence
bien
ma pauvre simone d'un couac on sait
encore embarqué quelle en est la callas
rap très à l'aise pas gêné du tout du
tout - arabe
je me suis dit faisons en tout petits
dés fois qu'on marque pas et je parle
c'est géraud de base c'est à dire et je
veux pas vad
c'est moi que je suis le maître à bord
vous et moi un peu les gars là je
tripote l'eba étaient petits boutons
comme si j'aurais fait ça depuis
toujours comme ça dans mes ancêtres
personne n'aurait jamais gardé une
chèvre de famille ils ont pris acte du
lourd en lien avec les collègues au mont
ste pas on est des touristes le covan a
ainsi dit moulay ahmed benyahia ouled
nous souhaite la bienvenue à bord et
bien forfait c'est pas de faire des
remarques l'armée française d'un café à
son travail
simplement je dis à monsieur kader et
qui était à côté avoir comme avec le
service vers candice d'hôtesses et de
bonbons il vous nous voyez une moue
cadets au livre des cacahuètes
l'habitant mais sur anna dans quelque
chose de pas catholique à la note est
surpris hier 2 087 dur d'ailleurs c'est
local aviator arabe lui même qui nous a
demandé de les attacher
est ce que quelqu'un me donne du
monsieur vous êtes priés d'attaché vos
ceintures et des tonnes de cigarettes
rang quelle arrogance
je sais pas si la sortie de cet appareil
le surdo réprobation quoi n'empêche que
plein de tout le voyage les incidents
n'ont pas cessé de se multiplier
monsieur cadoret vite vers les nigauds
m'a volontairement pendant exacerbée
déjà l'île où s'est excusé et quelqu'un
parmi les passagers qui pourraient me
passer un big palaze à la fin que je
fasse mes calculs sinon on peut pas
décoller ça fait sérieux
moi j'avais mon waterman à plumes
incorporé plaqué or que simone m'a
offert pour ma nomination à la direction
du service réclamation de la maison à
cet objet final avec sexy jeune des fils
pas du tout comme les autres au ps et
que les écrits de droite à gauche reçoit
terme à niveau rendent complètement
salle au pire comme team roulera quand
yves houle aura encore moins de
prétendre après que soi disant ils
auraient été égarés vote waterman cadeau
tu rigole oui mais oui d'ailleurs
l'école et moi c'est ce monsieur l'a
finalement c'est monsieur k d'or et qui
s'est dévoué ya passé sur ce stylo mid
et nous avons plusieurs volets mais tout
le seigneur sauter pendant toute la
traversée il a pas arrêté de se faire
remarquer ma main c'était un peu
assoupie avec les collègues mais
l'intense chaleur qui a régné dans la
carlingue illner qui commençait sur la
chaîne info mon ami on est tous très
bien sûr société encore lui lot
l'indigène qui criait saint soit honnête
je lève où ça sent le brûlé tous à
renifler comme des cockers de la can et
dit tout bas monsieur cadors il s'amuse
avec nous quoi tu adores est très fin
psychologue me dit il s'amuse très bien
parfait
amusons-nous la france est à quatre
pattes est tout à fait dans le sens de
l'histoire
[Rires]
le maréchal lyautey et moi nous
inclinons et juste après il se met à
hurler dans son micro comme un
hystérique
ah là là tout est comme toi oh là là là
nous dit qu elle voulait me dire où je
me dis no 6 ou plus je n'en ai pas la
moindre idée
une ambiance d'installer tisseur de
cogiter au boire de tous les deux à
myennes lasimant n'était pas non plus
très belle à voir
on m'a dit vous rendez vous jeudi bouge
pas six mois ne pousse pas de petit
match et la compagnie qui est
responsable
n'importe quel terminal si l'avion tome
7 et 10 ans dans leurs tarder
cela finit pas se pose c'est déjà
quelque chose
earl a partout des arabes des arabes des
haras que ça que sa caisse à les porter
bon ça normal
les douaniers et les policiers à
l'emploi voilà une fois aux actualités
ça ce prime très correctement il a l'air
de très bonne famille nationale
l'ieee sont chez eux encore lui le mois
à l'autre là le roi il est pas mal ce
garçon il est pas mal attachés hiller
tient la dragée haute à tous ces va nu
pieds je me demande si l'ap un peu de
safran c'est ce mois là quoi qu'il en
soit jeudi à simone c'est la dernière
fois qu'on met les pieds en colonie
il faut pas me dire raciste c'était à
nous dans l'entreprise nous apprécions
énormément de travail en or africain et
bien que les avons laissé installer leur
village leur espèce de bidonvilles n'a
tout prenant chantier et mama le fon des
poules de pouvoir de la maison monsieur
bourdieu qui est un homme pas libéral
plutôt à gauche arrivait un jour au
bureau complètement retourné en usage
des deux patients voiture près des
baraquements nord africains il faut
absolument faire quelque chose pour ces
malheureux ne pouvons pas tolérer une
pareille misère en plus ça se voit de la
route
c'est très fâcheuses pour le standing de
la maison eh bien nous nous sommes
réunis en comité nous avons voté des
crédits
croyez moi vous pouvez passer en voiture
près de chez nous vous verrez plus rien
de tout ça ils ont fait construire un
mur
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas vous selon la suite ils barrent le
bol dans le métier que double la pho bo
papé et je sais j'ai l'air un peu con
ah non mais l'uniforme y est pour
beaucoup un à ses fans afin de me dit
toujours tu as signé sans réfléchir et
me dit et j'ai demandé aux autres ils
ont fait pareil on argumente pas comme
ça la folie taille et d'examen tout
cantons du sud soit moi je suis passé de
1,6 jazz qui me disent combien je dois
alors des examens
j'ai dû je sais pas 15 va dire ont signé
là qu avant gérard tout faux j'ai tout
bon l'arnaqué c'est utile comme métier
tu le chef qui dit tout le temps
l'agent de police et à l'automobile ce
que travaux est à la sec
et puis c'est bien l'unique femme se
sent trahie et les gonzesses parce que
quand on était plus qu un bon exemple
eux jouent impressionné par le passé les
gens nous aiment pas c'est vrai
passionné là pour les protéger elle est
là pour les défendre
eh ben j'ai remarqué les gens plus il ya
deux flics ou pour de plus au port c'est
dans les manifs passionnés ou dans les
manifs on est obligé de taper on peut
pas pour le plaisir
un nom qui ont fait la fête dans une
manie pied et fils dégradée dans les
cheveux longs ne reconnaît pas et puis
dans les manifs et il ya les appariteurs
les appariteurs si flics en civil comme
un humaniste pas la feuille qui cassent
les vitrines les décors outre cet apport
de 16 ouvriers des étudiants
déconnez pas se repiquer
et on fut gracié gillot tu as pas le
goût monte à poissy à l'impliquer
[Musique]
une phrase hier et launay taper sur un
unique et non dit était une bavure face
à la france l envi de balai à jablah
fumeurs impeccable l'impasse ya les gens
qui disent oui à la police un refuge
pour les alcooliques qu'on n'a pas voulu
et fo ptt mulhouse nous en fait c'est
exagéré parce que moi je vois je suis
pas un gros commissariat mais je vois
déjà elle ou commissariat que je suis
est elle la pauvre que jusqu'au but il y
en a au moins un chef qui boivent pas
mais jeudi en masse et comme dans tous
les propos il faut garder brebis
galeuses qui se glisse on à robert 500
démarrant si la troupe à lui tout seul
et bien c'est comme un ami tim qu'on
m'envoie des rôles
l'autre jour et invictus il vient pour
chercher une carte d'identité pas et tu
me donneras grèce de son coiffeur
car c'est la joie
en face à face avec le plan de la main
le dos comme ça ici ça fait mal ne
savent pas déconner avec ça non non et à
rigoler pas là je m'en fous je compte
des noms très connus comme j'aimerais
qu'ils ont des traces après le flop
porter plainte un homme inquiet pour
porter plainte il faudra étudier le
commissariat dans l'ensemble ils
viennent panapress plein on sur la
gueule alors à pau l'avait attachée avec
les mauves est à la grille parce qu'on
fait des jeux robert été chercher ça
sont de nature à berne pour le message
lui fait pas fourni à l'armée qui est la
chose du tout y n'y a pas coupé se fait
découper les choux ou huit minutes les
bleus il a le nom artis membres et des
connaissances ou de 31,6 mon parrain
blanc et au bout de trente blâmons pas
en a qu'ont ces disciplines où peut se
dégrader
et comment
tiens un exemple l'eau joue j'essaie de
faction une intersection affectés à la
surveillance des usagers bon en clair je
buvais carrefour
j'étais là depuis un bon quart d'heure
je foutais rien savait qu'on fout rien
même quand enfin vous rendez pas compte
de ce que vous faites des voix boulot
mais nous quand on fait rien je suis là
je foutais rien et j'aurais aimé qu'ils
s'amenaient thiam qui papier je sentais
qu elle demande à une aumône ridicule
aux deux potes tu veux pour ba genre de
mecs louches apitoie basané 1
ah oui parce que nous nous apprend à
connaître et meklouche a fait des stages
avec fléchettes ou peu saoulé celui-là
était pas franchement louche mais c'est
franchement basané alors ouais je
l'avais vu le mec mais je faisais mine
que rien tiens je vais vous le faire je
fais bien alors mais je m'entraîne voilà
le type il était là elle tourne et puis
je sens si tu faisais pas le genre
devait pas si müller alors finalement
attendre la finale volume et qui
s'appelle pardon monsieur l'agent
excusez moi parce que socoprim indiqué
en ce qu'il est excusez moi
le commissariat de police parce que je
parle de mes papiers d'identité excusez
moi je vais faire une déclaration ce que
je veux moi oui vous avez vos papiers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la conférence que je vais avoir
l'honneur de faire devant vous sous la
présidence honorifique effectué de
monsieur anatole béchard le grand
spécialiste de la sinusite et des
refroidissements et de ce que fut gel
gras le premier alpiniste il fut le
premier à monter sur le foot on aura
très aujourd'hui à mon délire exploit
comment j'ai planté le drapeau français
au sommet du mont mama les repas 12
mille mètres d'altitude
je ne m'étonnerais pas davantage sur
moi-même beaucoup d'autres l'ont déjà je
rappellerai brièvement les tripes des
conférences données à l'issue de mes
nombreux voyages week end chez les
pygmées la bourboule et son fan club
vingt mille lieues sous les mers il sait
faire avec ces mecs une confession en
passons j'étais un peu las vous
voyagerez je décide et non le consacrer
nous attend à la rédaction de mon livre
de souvenirs qui doit paraître à
incessamment chez arthème fayard et
l'entretien de mon jardin suspendu eh
bien voyez-vous je vends bourgeoise un
beau matin d'octobre en pleine giboulées
jour une le professeur méchas appelé en
consultation le conseil l'aptitude ma
décision fut prise en un instant jacques
après le mot mama n'est pas 12 mais une
anecdote aux façons c'était en main
non tu d'une bourse délivrés par les
échanges culturels et du musée de la
femme je vision de partir dans les plus
mauvaises solutions
si megan les bagages sont vite fait un
bon tri coup en enrôlant un pot de
saintdo pour enduire m'est cher et le
plus important le drapeau français
offert par les anciens de la pétanque de
roubaix dont vous connaissez tous la
devise
prends ta boule dans la bave au bout
pour les bus réponse je décidé de faire
de l'auto stop jusqu'à marseille
je ne post est donc au bord de la route
et attendit avait qui motorisait pour me
rapprocher du thésée au bout de trois
heures un motocycliste me prit en troupe
régal nous on est dans sa famille à dix
kilomètres de là et grim afrique une
grange pour y passer la nuit
les troncs d'arbres je passais sur les
différentes péripéties mon voyage
ma journée à béziers mon bas dans le
gange ou vers lien au 17e rang balises
étaient tous les partenaires
on arrive directement au coeur même du
tibet dans la petite ville de où on
dernière at avant l'ascension deux
choses importantes occuper mon esprit la
première acheter des provisions de
bouche partout et la deuxième trouver
des indigènes pour m'indiquer le
meilleur chemin
deux jeunes un dégel s'étend à ma vue
frapper le front avec l'index en si la
création coutume je pense en confiance
je décidé de partir sur le champ à la
première à tous les deux chercheurs pas
s'enfuir en emportant tout bête mais
vaine
je me trouvais dans seul et nu au pied
des neiges éternelles
mais fidèle à ma devise va jusqu'au bout
je veux drapé dans quel que soit l'âge
est parti vers ce sommet m'agite
immerger les moulins une anecdote en
passant juge tient à souligner il
sévèrement cavernes d'avalanche en
avalant je me rapproche lentement du
sommeil à 8500 mètres d'altitude super
baccouche enveloppe nos pieds dans une
bonne nouvelle coupe et je continue
toujours joyeuse la une avec toi t'as
pas cent j'étais furieux clémente envers
leur faveur et avallon chavanges et
soudain vous allez voir c'est
impressionnant quand on est seul à
mettre la nature
soudain au détour d'un pic comme comme
vous diriez comme ça il ya le foot et on
prenait pour un fou
il me semble entendre une voix étrange
je pense que ma raison ces gars mot sang
se glace dans mes veines serait ce par
hasard l'abominable homme des neiges
[Rires]
na mais l'esprit dans les journaux ce
qui rend pas ne l'ont jamais vu jamais
touché jamais approché jamais touché sa
fille
il m'a simplement derrien rhume par un
impôt imposition des pâtes des grosses
pannes une chapelle et des mains quoi je
sais pas pas faire de mon drapeau je lui
ai donné si vous savez ce qu'ils on a
fait les mêmes et non pas ici non non
non ça y est j'ai dès maintenant il est
abominable
[Applaudissements]
unité proximité vous êtes concentré je
suis concentré vous êtes conseiller les
concentrés comme on dit chez nestlé
alors je vais vous demander vos qualités
de me dire quel est le signe zodiacal de
monsieur monsieur et des sous le double
signe zodiacal du lion et du fonctionnel
de hongrie quel est son caractère
impulsif et simultanées oui ils sont à
venir
monsieur a son avenir devant lui mais il
aura dans le dos chaque fois qu'ils
vendent mais tous il est génial
une absolument génial voulez-vous me dis
là plaisr il est le signal de
mademoiselle est né sous le triple signe
bénéfiques de la vierge du taureau et du
sagittaire avant de s'en servir et quel
est son avenir conjugale et prolifique
prolifique il aura des enfants
oui et des jumelles des jumelles combien
une paire voilà avec avec l'aco à l étui
il est merveilleux il voit tout il sait
tout pour sénilité
voulez-vous me dire la plaisante et quel
est le signe zodiacal de monsieur les
petits de mercurochrome quelles sont ses
goûts et messieurs les goûts sportifs
sportif quel est son préféré je pense qu
ça il peut le pratiquer sans
inconvénients oui à condition toutefois
de se méfier se méfier de qui de quoi
le cinquième personne dans son entourage
qui pourrait penser que sa compétence
dans le domaine de la [ __ ] pratique
gers et n'influence fâcheuse ce son
comportement sentimentale et qu'est ce
que vous lui conseiller lui conseille de
changer de braquet et surveiller son
bilan c'est aussi l'étape les heures
dites quoi et quelle est la taille de
monsieur 1 m 78 de boue ont fait 56
ainsi avec 45 à plat ventre et 0 mètre
quatre-vingt deux roulés en boule à
relever et il pèse combien de fois par
mois d août mal son poids
rx ne parle pas bien français 78 kg san
jose en gal ils ont d'électricité eh
bien oui quel est son degré
d'instruction secondaire il a des
diplômes
oui monsieur licenciés licenciés ils
changeaient glc qui signifie qu'ils
travaillent au gain lafayette dès qu'on
l'a foutu à la porte
ap les à proximité vous me direz oublie
combien madame at-elle dedans en
devenant et de ne s'est pas fait pour me
dire et quelle est la nationalité de
madame en fait il est son père eskimos
et sa mère cette surprise et ta soeur
blanchard et balbin baguette
c'est pas beau oui aux insolences ou
prix mal élevés screw vague à 6,8 et
concentrez-vous un peu je vous trouve
bien le diluer tout seul tu les chaleurs
qui fait pas étonnant pour s'éviter
est-ce que je peux continuer à vous
poser des questions ou des bateaux est
limité et messieurs que voici que voilà
at il des complexes
oui monsieur fait un complexe tel
complexe certains moments il prend sa
vessie pour une lanterne et alors et
loris brute fr voici à présent quelque
chose de très très très important
pouvez-vous dire le numéro de la carte
d'identité de monsieur oui vous pouvez
le dire oui vous pouvez le dire oui
[Applaudissements]
mais bon c'est comme ça juste diane 1 à
st dervin la langue cgc parce que tu
trouves comment roger pro vie à cause de
ma grosse bouffe jédir je sais bien
c'est parce que je suis pas insensible
m'a gazé
ils disent de actuelle marceau forcé sur
leurs roses
seulement je me raconte pas si tu as
fait une guerre juste bien je préfère
que ma jeu des russes j'ai horreur de la
vulgarité et pis à ce jour et des pics à
mama je venais philémon sciences t'es un
bon j'arrive à l'intention de me dire ça
ma porte à clé dsk n'a pas besoin
d'attaquer à la porte
c'est mince pies ces personnes mad men
il a lancé je pense que c'était
peut-être ma fille est ainsi convié son
parapluie quelques cieux et puis je vous
disais pas que ce qui me retient comme
un jardin comme qu'elle n'appelle pas de
produits dismas de dépression film à
thèse d'après est bien josiane junte un
barouf
j'ai un temps où parler que c'est un
genre de meurtrier jeudi main c'est pas
avec est ce que j'ai de venir je suis
toute seule dans ma petit chat
heureusement sa dictature de franco
bolt a remporté ces pacifistes et au
zhejiang jose n'a pas tendu par un 4x
il m'arrivait de maximy tête de la co
promotion alors saisi demain parce que
je me dis voir un gène lac la corse
malchanceuse maintenant je vous rappeler
de l'autre jamais saisi un presse papier
j'ai passé la nuit blanche jusqu'à 7
heures sur mon lit tu va comme suit
blanche alors que j'arrive au salon café
à la patronne et si vous n'avez pas à
tenter votre sang cliente gt1 bull
j'ai dit que je m'énerve vraiment c'est
pas possible tu dis mais enfin j'ai mis
de la péta de faire mon travail c'est un
brushing à poster ou alors tu vas mettre
du personnel ma barbe y est c'est vrai
c'est pas tu as vécu mince
c'est ce que j'ai toujours aussi dingue
de jaude et moi je craque ça ne passera
pas j'ai entendu dire qu'il avait déjà
dit qu écrivent aux vedettes
alors je me suis dit 'pourquoi décrète
pas c'est vrai que je suis pas pu
masquer une autre
j'ai fait une lettre tu te dit que j et
demi ça veut dire jamais retient pas
pipi 1 ça fait drôlement bien que j'ai
pas payer cher que tu as monoprix attend
qu est ce que j aime me marc bellemare
est ce que j ai mis non c'est pas vrai
c'est la meilleure de l'année
je sais pas si c'est la chaleur ou quoi
mais je suis quand même on fait en ce
moment à huy suffisamment bien de 15 ans
avec j'ai mis pour commencer non jean ni
je t'aime mon joli je te veux je sais ce
qu'on a mises oscillent entre
parenthèses jonnhy ton sexe je les y
aider ses parents savez moi je n'ai
seulement je te veux c'est quand même de
réserver ces génies comme qui est beau
on se voit qu'il dépose ce travail opale
dix mois c'est simple elle quitta chine
je contrôle j'ai mis aussi ta liberté
c'est mon bonheur ça c'est beau comme
formule moi je vais trouver comme ça
j'ai réfléchi je suis une pas comme ce
sera pas qui c'est toute façon pourquoi
que gilles va s'arranger les dents parce
que mon fiancé dit que c'est ça qui fait
son charme
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de mines mais camara parce que
j'en ai fait beaucoup depuis sept ans
disons qu'ils ont un talent fou c'est
vrai il veut et puis j'adore sont des
gens qui sont qui n'hésite pas à
s'oublier pour être un autre et c'est ce
que je voudrais vous dire c'est que
quelques fours dit qu'un artiste sait
tout faire
tu sais tout faire aujourd'hui on s'est
tous fait un mime s'étouffer mais un
mime ne peut pas tout faire un jour je
devais me met quelqu'un qui n'a rien à
faire eh bien j'ai rien pu faire parce
que ne rien faire
ça peut se dire mais ça ne peut pas se
faire et depuis je pouvais partir je ne
pouvais pas le faire parce que le
personnage qui n'avaient rien à faire en
plus la verrière à dire et le directeur
avait bien spécifié mme avery surtout
pensez bien ce que vous avez à faire
c'est à dire en fait penser à rien il
avait ajouté surtout ne le dit pas
et je lui avais donné ma parole de mines
que je ne dirai rien
alors je suis entré sur scène comme ça
j'ai commencé à ne rien faire sans rien
dire ça l'air de rien mais faut le faire
il suffit pas de le dire
et paradoxalement plus je ne faisais
rien plus les gens disaient qu'est ce
qu'il fait le but n'est pas fou il
voyait bien je faisais quelque chose
mais comme c'était rien ils se
demandaient ce que j'étais venu faire et
les critiques dans la salle voyez bien
que je ne faisais rien et que je le
faisais bien et s'attendait à plus et
moi qui vais je ne faisais rien je
pouvais pas faire moins les gens à la
salle qu'il voyait rien ils ont commencé
à trouver à redire donc au moins faire
un geste
avoir un bon mouvement pour ce que
voyant moi j'ai fait le seul geste
pouvait se permettre
quelqu'un qui n'a rien à faire sans
qu'on dit il en fait trop j'ai fait un
geste d'impuissance alors les gens dans
la salle qu'est ce qui dit
alors là j'ai rompu le silence j'ai dû
mesdames et messieurs mais je n'ai rien
dit qu'est-ce que jamais ni l'ats le
directeur rhino non seulement je paye un
mime à ne rien faire il le fait pas mais
en plus il ne tient pas sa parole il
parle il a dit monsieur vous n'êtes même
pas bons à rien alors le lendemain dans
la presse quand android comme on dit les
critiques comme j'avais rien fait ils
n'ont rien dit mais en bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle habite dans un épicier la aux
clients vous a merdé pas la vie ça fait
demeure que j'attende à votre cagna
d'épicerie la caisse qui serait pas à ça
je faisais la sieste quand abadie dehors
le 6h15 la vallée va demain ceux ci s'en
remet à une question vous voulez suisse
en laye poivre nature faut saluer et
soyez polis la prière de molson nature
ne parle plus du côté nature vous voulez
europe ont complété mardi nerfs ok
cagade en sifflant aux deux mondes
camembert allez hop ça ira plus vite
[Rires]
avec les asticots sans les asticots
[Musique]
watch de corps
il va me faire revenir la transpiration
j'ose même pas lui demander le jus
d'orange
il va me demander avec les bulls et les
bulles
je n'ai plus c'est pas plus mal var ont
gagné du temps comme ça allez vous
mettez une petite bière et la bière je
vous de la grotte tambours de groupes
comme pour mac est de 6 5 à 12 ans aux
facs de corps ou écoutez moi bien je
voudrais du ver rouge de préférence le
vais vous le groupe et dans une
bouteille voyez avec une étiquette
collée avec de la colle à allonger un
peu plus là bas vous énervez je me donne
moi la beauté une étiquette collée avec
la colle vous donne moi la bouteille
beauté un vert bouteille plastique on
les petits commerces art là haut vous
plaignez toute l'année que vous n'êtes
plus de pognon et plus de clients me
faut voir pose est devenu un maire
d'arles et voilà tout ça parce que hier
je les ai battus à la pétanque
aujourd'hui ce coup d'oeil les nerfs en
boule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si mon papa mais voyez vie qui me disait
toujours si j'étais en france il ya des
choses que je l'aimerais faire aller
visiter la grande synagogue de notre
dame de paris et dîner chez maxim's je
veux pas paraître je suis chez maxim's
et il est mon invité titre posthume
mettrait d'hôtel
pour commencer vous allez nous donner
n'est pas donné
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on va chez
maxim's non plus un an vous allez nous
donner et comment si j'attends quelqu'un
une jatte en personne j'ai des jeunes
avec moi-même comprendre la même chose
alors vous allez nous donner in et un
bal des champignons et nous attendait
démarquer page et me méfie des
champignons ça me rappelle que j'ai un
ami qu'il est mort deux jours après
l'avoir mangé des champignons dans la
marmite et phalloïde voyons notre et
chose a réuni et des mers ou la santé
des bêtes ohlala ou quand je pense que
ça existe des araignées comme ça dans la
mer avec des pâtons rouge et velits j'ai
comme les jambes de ma concierge
voilà ça ça me plaît vous allez me
donner in et saumon fumé avec supplément
qu'est ce qui va vous en donner comme
complément à cette en supplément des
prix c'est pourquoi il est en supplément
des prix parce qu'il vient d'où des
scandinavie si je comprends bien c'est
moi que je les paye son voyage il y en a
pas un qui vient des plis près non parce
que les pressions qui viennent de loin
j'ai mes filles il arrive souvent
fatigués par le voyage
il y en a pas mal ne sais pas comment ça
s'appelle la bestiole avec les pinces là
que ça commence avec un cas et pas par
la crise est là la crise
y en a pas ça entre 10 et ac l'as roma
en amérique à barrichello bra la roma à
l'américain ben voila je vais prendre ça
et on verra offir maysir j'ai dit on
verra offir masi f qui fit comprendre
les princesses et du vin
j'ai pris là aux mains parce qu'il ya
pas des prix on dirait bien pourrait
nous offrir l'apéritif quand même à ce
prix là nous n'est pas des sauvages tout
même
et bonjour monsieur vous êtes coin
sommelier il n'ya pas de sot métier lui
et moi je cite un saunier est assez pour
les vins rouges je croyais que des
primates l'embrasser 10 homélie bon
écoute et aujourd'hui je vais pas boire
les vins de monsieur tout le monde je
vais un vin de qualité très supérieure
je regarde pas à la dépense mais je vais
le meilleur et le moins cher
alors qu'est ce que vous allez me donner
des bons dans les grands bordeaux
d'accord dernière page allons-y
qu'est ce que je lis la chaffoteaux et
maury à chapeau dépouillés ah bon
j'aurais dû prendre mes lunettes et la
châteauneuf dis pas tiens il fait dans
les vins aussi
la carafe d'eau est gratuite
bon on va déjà la prendre la carafe
d'eau est alors pour colorer un peu
écoutez moi je me connais pas je vous
fais confiance je ne connais pas qu'est
ce que vous allez me proposer les bons
et un mouton rothschild voilà une bonne
idée oui comment si je les préfère dans
une coin dans une grande qui v et non
pas dans une grande cuvette et jeep et y
bouteille ça suffit d'un petit car info
comment vous en avez et millésimé 1900
combien 1929 il vous en reste encore 17
époque
moi c'est pareil dit non il me reste des
anciens modèles des caleçons molletonnés
j'arrive pas à les liquider et vous
laissons le dire combien 1530 15 france
et pas cher 3500 nouveaux 150000 point
vous étiez c'est pas les taux longs cent
cinquante mille points pour une
bouteille de vin il ya des croisières
était lié d'épicés pendant dix jours
c'est un coup abandonné la prostate ça
faites la carte bleue ici fait pas
l'accabler de la carte orange bon écoute
et amener mois déjà la carafe d'eau et
puis on va réfléchir si j'ai encore soif
on va apprendre les bains bon là ça me
rappelle qu'un du ciel avec mon père
dans une haie grande restaurant qu'est
ce qui va me regarder comme un fou je
vous parle pas vous je me parle à moi et
on était allé dans un grand restaurant
des garçons et la diversité des vins il
attendait derrière et mon père est dit
qu'est-ce qu'il est à la tente derrière
moi avec la bouteille à la mer
il m'a versé un fond de verre il faut
pas qu'il va mêler compté pour environ
six lots à voilà les homards à
l'américain la banale et voilà voilà
avaya piste car cascades et aux marques
donc j'ai dit la prise des casques et
des rumeurs là qu'est ce qu'il est
arrivé lé tout casser il a fait un
atterrissage forcé génome à l'américain
qu'il appelait l anglaise avant
d'arriver dans mon assiette la main qui
pincent la bauma ça dépend ce parquet
payer pour les dépenses non comment ils
se sont bâties dans les viviers et bien
alors apportez moi le vainqueur par les
vaincus bon sens
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi qui sont il a pu pour le
rasoir j'ai recommencé
j'ai recommencé
[Applaudissements]
nos analystes
passion dont trois 3 ans je me suis
encore trompé de côté
vous avez là quatre bassines 4 et plus
et 50 kg de patates dans le vert ont des
pommes de terre je vous ai convoqué pour
éplucher les pommes de terre parce que
la machine est en panne
comment il n'ya pas d'ouvriers pour le
faire question pourquoi je vous ai
convoqué poids eh bien je pense que pour
que mes amis de nuit et moi même nous
libérions c'est féculents de leur
enveloppe charnelle
combien de morts est plus hachée patate
violent j'avais compris aller au travail
et que ça ce n'est que ça saute ça te
dérange pas non je rejoigne mais croit
pas merci il ya bien comment s'y prendre
quand tu prends la patate dans une main
les plus réputés plus bas j'aurais
préféré peluches et des douces lorsque
je pense qu'il serait plus simple espace
et de prendre le féculent de vendre une
extrémité et avec le couteau d'abord
c'est un mouvement rotatif afin
d'obtenir une seule pollution gagne un
temps considérable s'est très bien bien
laquelle branges la moins ça
je vais y aller une semaine si ma mère
savait que travaillant au noir
j'ai entendu qu'une phrase
les cadets vous une a dit
sept jours
là tu as une tête qui respire le
masochisme vision m'expliquer comment on
épluche les pratiques de la jad évite à
peine de moitié si tu es plage pleuvait
que les autres aller parce que c'est toi
c'est dur je vous l'avais pour lui dire
que c'était moi je sois tu sais l'armée
avant tout c'est l'injustice oui ces
fumiers van persie pourquoi bouger leur
ego dénommé pas ils vont chanter vous
avez déjà tiré oui avec marie-chantal on
me parle de chasse
ah oui on va l'année dernière de son
parti en safari avec papa tels que vous
voyez j'ai chassé l'éléphant bien moi je
n'ai jamais que le ferait sens
et bien moi dernièrement figurez vous
que j'ai chassé la bonne ben moi j'ai
tiré la chasse
à temps
pardon monsieur excusez-moi sergent puis
je vous posais une question indiscrète
vous ne soyez pas assia territoire parce
que je suis alsacien durant je sais pas
qui tu es mais je te soupçonne doigts
oui je suis de strasbourg j'aurais
plutôt cru que ne l'est la forêt noire
qu'attend jouit good vivement l'as rome
s'est pas tu t'en quelles facs toi de
moi j'étais à sciences po tout ça qu'on
finir sur ce coup de tête et ben moi
j'ai raté linda maman était folle et toi
tu étais de tuer de quelle région
je suis 100 de la france trouvé d'accord
mais de quelles facs
c'est dans le centre de la france de
quelle fight tube est riche mais en
désaccord mais avant je vous parle plus
bon tu vas pas te fâcher pour serge en
dit long
oui il a une simca 1000 avec la queue du
tigre qui prend la menthe avec pourquoi
vous dites que le sergent est un conte
faut dire ce qui est c'est pas une
lumière je trouve mais c'est pas de sa
faute et sont détenus à toi tu trouveras
quoi alors toute façon il est pas
content c'est un triple attentat comme
vous et vous dans mon bureau
vous côtoyez des dangers allez on en
produit l'an passé je me voyais des gars
est pas si dégueulasse que ça le macaque
hélas
plutôt toi de l'ag
[Applaudissements]
pierre desproges vous avez décidé à
votre tour d'écrire à une haute autorité
oui parce que je suis indignée mme wang
c'est une lettre ouverte à monseigneur
lustiger cher seigneur qu'il me soit
permis de m'indigner ici véhémentement
contre les insupportables attaques
portées régulièrement à la télévision à
mon athéisme militants par vos camarades
de goupillon il est intolérable de
siècle après la séparation de l'église
et de l'état
dans un pays qui poussent la laïcité
officielle au rang d'institution
nationale que des anti hat et hystérique
accapare l'antenne de la télévision le
dimanche matin avec des émissions
intitulée je cite la messe du dimanche
dans laquelle les minorités at et non
priante non bigot temps tu es mal
bêtifiante sont méprisés et bafoué et je
pèse mes mots au profit de grotesque
manifestation incantatoire d'une secte
arabe dont le monothéisme avoué est une
véritable insulte à darwin religion
gréco romaine et à ma soeur qui fait
bouddhistes dans un bordel de kuala
lumpur
voilà je précise que j'envoie par ce
même courrier une copie de cette lettre
à dieu et que ça va chier
s'appelant monsieur georges marchais
ouais ouais voilà j'arrive
bonjour avant bruyckere bonjour monsieur
marché mais dites moi qu'est ce que
c'est que ce chien que ben je sais pas
c'est un chien un chien des rues où il
est jacques brillet lire regarder
sociaux de plus près lui et j'ai trouvé
devant le faubourg saint honoré devant
l'elysée avec le collier
regardez ça ça doit être le chien
giscard et van persie
il a des envies de revient si ça doit
être ça et vous savoir alors moi je vous
écoute à europe 1 le matin gentiment à
8h30 son niveau est tout près tout rose
et la grande forme alors richert oui oui
et vous est ce que vous l'avez tous vu
ce marché mais moi j'ai pas de problème
j'ai un réveil téléphoner c'est youpi
qu'ils en a aucune autre pas vous avez
newbie andropov wii qui avons travaillé
dans un cagibi à chasser les taux oui
c'est lé top c'est des gens qui sont
accusés vers l'intelligence avec les
nîmois qui a déjà du mal en floride
ruscher et alors j'ai installé ligne
directe chez moi après paris et kremlin
c'est le seul appareil à que l'écouteur
compagnie
et qu'est-ce que vous prenez le matin
pour déjeuner à je suis frais jamais mon
café je mets juste un peu de sakhaline
ries s'est amusé on rit mais alors
comment s'est passé aux vacances le
marché mais devrait bien derrière le
rideau de fer comme d'habitude tu vas
dire qu'ils louent pour moi ils
rabaissent après moi j'ai un avantage
est que j'allais en union soviétique et
je peux en sortir je suis ni juif ni
intellectuel compromet cette même année
alors voilà et puis tout s'est très bien
passé à la fête de l'huma vous a pas vu
besoin il ait pu venir il y avait de la
place surtout au stand des droits de
l'homme y avait personne et parce en a
vendu 300 tonnes de merguez pour la fête
des travailleurs voire voilà dit quoi
monsieur oui monsieur marc chez moi
quand je vois la télévision jouer un peu
de ton du belge et j'ai d'abord j'ai pas
jamais à la télévision qui souvent
l'occasion de mon plein dans la
télévision
et oui comment je découvrais vous n'êtes
plus en plus d'audience faut que ce soit
en europe 1 la tvn on voit que vous
partez avec souriant toujours bronzé
un point est souriant weepu est souriant
m je vous l ai un comme ce marché grâce
à des cadres et le sourire pays
d'afrique est naturel de non cadré c'est
l'échec
oui voilà m'insurgeais pas que je vais
sembla bouchardon balsam d'en masquer la
dernière fois que j'ai vu à la tv
c'était même la première fois que je le
voyais j'ai cru que mon post est
hébergée 50 ans wade bouchardon se dit
elle va aggraver le déficit de la
sécurité sociale ces femmes là rien à
regarder on tombe malade cizek ce marché
oui vous avez quelque chose à nous dire
mais oui j'ai quand même un message à
faire passer d'eux mêmes devant vos
nombreux téléspectateurs et pâteuse with
all 1 mes chers camarades et je suis
heureux et ému d'être là car vous le
savez j'aime adresses ont renvoyé hier
est renvoyé à 30,3 yeahs aux masses
populaires
on craint laborieuse lit de l'autre côté
ah oui et vont défendre les intérêts
fondamentaux des grands intérêts de tous
contre la droite et giscard d'estaing
qui était financée par les grands trice
l'international noces et les grandes
sociétés multinationales au vrai j'ai
beaucoup ri sachez le oui parce que
drucker encore eût-il fallu que vous le
souci oui et j'ai boccoli génie les hev
des grands aspire à faire du parti pc
pierre cardin calme axe qui habille le
capitalisme c'est l'exploitation de l'or
parlons mais soyez rassuré plus cher oui
le socialiste exactement quand faire
ball messieurs marché vis à vis je vous
ai amené un petit cadeau oui d'accord
oui c'est un des ouvriers ça me ferait
plaisir que c'est pas une bombe à
retardement vous inquiétez pas non tiens
les stands de tir à la fête de l'huma
effet près visiter s'ils en avaient mis
à boeing de korean air lines a et celui
qui tirait dans le mille gagner à la
carte du parti
si vous savez ce que c'est c'est mon
emblème c'est un peu comme mon cerveau
c'est une noix de coco mais pour un coco
à la noix comme vous séduire dehors et
c'est mou dedans thiery de lyon
[Applaudissements]
voilà bien alors vous savez mont saint
michel que notre émission va un peu
partout dans le monde francophone et
variés comme vous avez l'art d'imiter un
petit peu de prendre tous les accents je
vous demande et de saluer car avec un
décalage cette émission va arriver à
noël après noël peut être après le 1er
janvier vous a donc souhaité un bon noël
et un bon 1er janvier bonnes fêtes de
fin d'année on va commencer par les mels
puisqu'ils sont les plus proches de nous
ils nous reçoivent également c'est sûr
j'aimerais si c'est possible m'adresser
à tous nos amis belges
ce serait si sympathique une fois et
surtout leur dire que comme ma grand
mère était belge parce qu'elle avait une
pizza cacher à bruxelles qui marchait
très bien oui et c'était petite rue des
bouchers je vous embrasse tous sur
toutes vos bouches
je suis je suis maintenant label'vie
beau noël au suisse oui mais alors là
pour les suisses le seul problème c'est
que on a tellement peu de temps dans
l'émission pour leur souhaiter un joyeux
noël
parce qu'il parle quand même pas très
très vite alors faudra faire une autre
émission pour vient on se met un bon
noël est un mauvais oeil aux allemands
arias et en ouvrir en john grosses
cartes et en étant malade afrique du
nord la tunisie nous sommes reçues en
tunisie en algérie au maroc
et raconte en inde et au sol et les
arbres de noël de 10 et les boules
partout à tout autant à toi ça va bien
et met en relation on redescend
maintenant on va vers l'afrique noire
celle que vous connaissez bien
si vous trouvez ça mais je voudrais vous
souhaiter à tous un grand jouet noël
même s'il n'y a pas d'arbres de ça
permet de parler et je voudrais vous
dire que vous avez de la chance de par
michel drucker en couleur et nos parts
noir et blanc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les personnes parties il n'est pas
impossible qu'un jour par satellite sans
elysées à y encore beaucoup plus loin au
japon en chine au pays du soleil levant
alors pour eux c'est bien vrai
[Applaudissements]
avec quelque chose dont tu peut habiller
que chez bouygues on cherche on cherche
assure coûteux qu'est ce qu'on va lui
mettre à parler sa coupelle elle a tout
essayé chez vous la wii écoute il faut
quelque chose pour ce soir apple voilà
madame nous avons trouvé voilà notre
dernière création
on voit c'est pas mal cette origine il
fait passer tout de suite à ces voix là
vous mettez un petit oui oui ça va aller
ça allait bien vient il ya jeu remplit
assez mais évidemment si ça déborde vous
ne pourrez pu le faire oui oui ça fera
pas traîné c'est vrai je suis emmerdé et
c'est normal oui parce que je grossis en
ce moment on s'en fout complètement
merci est ce qu'il y à d'autres tailles
hollande a par la suite d'écoutés aucun
problème on a tout l'état on va jusqu'au
sang jusqu'au sang oui évidemment
jusqu'au sens libre d'envoyer à
marie-pierre on essaie la paix
c'est rognon vous allez vous chercher
des trucs pareils vous savez avec nicole
nous avons voulu faire du jamais fait du
jamais vu voilà nous appelons ce petit
ensemble sacs poubelles
oui écouté par ses démons tu pensais je
jouais bien vu dans une octave à huy et
bien non et bien non madame
oui sauf désolé mais ça n'existe
pendriez pleut à ses standards et à
partir des grandes feuilles nous ne
faisons plus que dans le gris j'ai lancé
pas j'ai réécouté avec chaleur avec les
boks transpire un mélo adam un non
madame métro vous ce n'est pas de la
transpiration un choix et non un sac
poubelle ou fait émettre une très fine
vapeur d'eau qui dilate les pores de la
peau pour la débarrasser de ses moindres
impuretés chère madame vous voyez que ça
doit vraiment rien à voir avec de la
transpiration encore mieux jouer à lui
tout petit mois qu'est ce que je vais
mettre comme chaussures avec un [ __ ]
mais moi alors ferons un petit mon père
vous savez nous avons les boots qui
colle avec l'ensemble est toute une
collection de robben tout ce déballage
je veux que je te dise un peu plus vos
mains égoutter non seulement on a lille
espère tous là également les pies noires
bien les draps et double rideau et où la
wii ou là et puis les parfois aussi les
bases la courbe projet sera par la suite
me direz c'est pour dans les airs is
useful espèrent-elles omar chef du peu
pour la coin des rues mais si vous
permettez ça vous donne une main du
plastique mais voilà les problèmes en
amont à droite oui je le perds un peu le
talon bas je passerais bien l'article de
mions ouvriers au nom vous savez si vous
mettez le petit souk est par exemple
c'est ça avoir la bonne vie trop chaud
c'est le renard ou bien s'en suivent les
fenêtres et la sacra rien comme artix en
moi on s'est totalement étanche
oui mais voilà le pied court le pied
d'orgue cette ag c'est jouir la neige et
s'amusent sous la pluie
qualité de sa poupe se voir écouter
madame j'irai même plus loin la qualité
de sa poupe ce vie n'est-ce pas nicole
moi je dirais même plus c'est une
seconde pour malawi la vérité j'ai un
vernissage ce soir je le met directement
pessah vieux il y aura beaucoup de monde
mon mari m'a approché pour écouter
madame s'il ya du monde et en plus la
chaleur je vais vous dire que votre mari
il faudra plus que l'accroché on va même
adhérez-vous service entre vous ce soir
ça va très fort collins vous poser une
question
on avance oui qu à l'arrière du médecin
ne pose aucun problème du tout mais
combien pardon oui le prix de ce
ravissant veut dire à louis marie tiens
vous allumez oui oui alors le bustier
vous fera mille la jupe 2000 oui il est
beau et vous seuls 4000 as well as tu
viens de nous pour un petit temps 5 qui
est pas marqué oui complète mois au
mieux c'est vrai qu'est-ce qu'il est
d'amener un petit aguichant parisien
petit b brillant parisien petit sourire
craquant parisien sur petit et et l'iran
au parisien évidemment j'ai rien panier
on tue tête fellini médias se disent les
jarrets le petit étang mieux d'écouter
chère madame surtout pour cocktails oui
vous avez tout de suite pas le côté
pratique de sagbo par exemple vous
voulez ramener quelques toasts
oui vous les mettez dans cette poule
voilà et puis en arrivant chez vous vous
mettez le tout offre et sacs ou
directement au frigo ça fait super moi
ou pas c'est complètement polyvalent et
l'art le lendemain à votre tenue reste
fraîche pas juste un petit coup d'épongé
lice impeccable
j'entends bien que je peux répondre est
une éponge grattoir pour lui ça sera
bien pour moi je crois que ça pousse ça
va être pas mais madame sa poupe c'est
la puissance industrielle au service de
mousse l université
à écouter oui je vais le prendre et puis
je me dépêchais pourquoi va-t-elle
sisters vous inquiétez foyer label qui
passe à 6 heures
ah je suis emballé un ah oui ça c'est
les rebelles ayant marqué mana illa
temps d'aller encore réellement
d'engagement emballé je le prends en
carrière je me gardais si on croit
carrément je suis plein du jour écoutez
madame si vous êtes plane on va vous
descendre
[Applaudissements]
st pascal tu m'entends pascal papa et
maman vient d'arriver aux sports d'hiver
oui tout va bien tout va bien écoute moi
pascal avant que grand mère vient de
s'occuper de vous je voudrais que tu
fasses à manger pour toi et ta petite
soeur crippa youpi craybas youpi papa
malhotra écoute pascal voilà ce que tu
fais tu ouvre le frigo
tu as dit reste dans le frigo et ajusta
fait réchauffer les rays je vais faire
la cuisine
qu'est ce que tu veux faire comme
cuisine des pâtes
beaucoup pensent que vous allez manger
toute la semaine des pâtes des pâtes à
la boue denis
qu'est ce que c'est sain c'est une
recette de ton copain budoni et que
c'est sa recette des pâtes avec de la
viande mais où vous avez trouvé d'avion
c'est budoni qui l'a ramené dans son
cartable
alors il a gardé cette viande toute la
journée à l'école dans son cartable
elle est comment s'habille en demande
lui commander sa viande correct elle est
correcte d'accord mais qu'est ce que
vous mettez avec cette viande la crème
fraîche qui était dans le frigo et ça
fait de moi tu es dans le frigo quoi
elle est déjà dans l'eau avec les pâtes
la viande il ketchup passe pas vous
donner parfois vous ne niez pas sony est
tout ouïe à sa place tout cas sa place à
l'horizon 2012 comment tu t'appelles et
milou emilio n'est pas un méchant garçon
toi on leur parle loi tepa non regardant
la casserole dis moi ce que tu vois une
casserole les pattes
rose c'est normal
avec de la viande noir oui je viens dans
de l'eau qui est jaune pour k les jaunes
au tamis du safran d'accord tamise
tu es plus rien maintenant tu carrie pas
trop caricom à l'eau qu'est ce qu'il
fout là j'entends ces bouquets vous le
chocolat est pourquoi vous mettiez du
chocolat les pattes maintenant annoncer
des src à part c'est le désert de vent
mais qu'est-ce-qui moussante enseigne la
casserole mode mais où vous l'avez
trouvé cette casserole sous l'évier
mais sous l'évier c'est tous les
récipients qui sont plastique
alors forcément sur les mettez sur le
feu fo la casserole ou pas soit parce
qu'elle passera pascal il ramasse le
chocolat et plastique fondu avec les
pascal pascal pascal postale ne t'affole
pas ne t'affole pas si un le téléphone
du bout des doigts
si tu arrives à décoller le téléphone va
dans l'armoire et prend un drap non
surtout ce sale nom fath dans la chambre
de ma paye durement tu tires un drap
dudit tuées suite téléphone est une
éponge tous qui dégouline fais toi et
départ budoni et touil qu'est ce qui à
tour hier elles sont cuites l'est pas
pascal parce qu'elle était pas prend la
place de budoni devant les pattes alors
dis-moi où ils en sont les pains ya trop
de fumée écoute moi pascal prendre chef
plonge la roue hasard dans les pattes et
tire une patte tire sa faim bloc
écoute moi pascal tir dire tu as eu pas
de la thune à la pâte à une patte là bon
alors qu'août là n'ont fait la bouteille
boudry il m
il m il faut me pas il est bien on leur
fasse album écoutez bien mais quand vous
mangez les pas debout les pieds dans
plastique en mer harry rohmer arrive
[Applaudissements]